you
Thanks for watching, and I'll see you in the next one.
Oh wait. Oh shit, my model turned off! Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. That wasn't supposed to happen. You're muted on my stream, too. Hold on, hold on.
Uh, application audio capture, discord call. Okay, say something?
Stop party people. Okay. Hi. Hello. Okay. Hi. Let me connect my model again. Oh shit, my phone. Okay.
Hello. Apologies for the scoff. It was working before stream. It was. We even started early just in case, or we hopped on call early. Yeah.
Hey, well. Oh, I just realized audio is bad. Okay, let me turn that down a little bit. Is audio okay on my side? Your audio's fine. Yeah, is my audio okay?
Is the background music to voice ratio to Emmy ratio okay? Yeah, is it okay? Audio's fine? Come on, chat on my side. You gotta step it up. You gotta step it up.
We should tell them. Okay, we're both streaming on YouTube. So if you want to see the other person's perspective, because this is a two person perspective game, then you should go to the other person's stream too.
Um, I think I have you in the, in my, um, description. In my title, I should. Oh, yeah, yeah, me too, me too. So guys, yeah, click on that. Oh, like, go check out the other person too. Yes. Yeah, you're in my, why is my bottle lagging? Oh, yeah. Okay, okay.
Okay, thanks guys. Thanks for stepping up. Okay. Yeah, like you said, this is a tool, tool perspective thing. So I also have Emmy socials in the description of my stream, but you can also click the little at thing in the title, whatever you want.
Open it on two screens. Do will this shit. If you don't have two screens, open one on your phone and one on your computer, unless you broke, which I'm sorry.
Yeah, open them both up and watch them both. Okay. Okay. Are we ready to, oh wait, wait, wait, one more, one more announcement. The stream will only be one hour long because I'm going through a heat wave and I'm fucking hot in here. Yeah.
Yeah. Yes. Send some ice cream funds to me, please.
Don't do that. AC funds, let's go. We need to upgrade her to a new apartment, guys. We gotta step up.
No, it's okay. It's okay. Okay. Okay. Let's, let's, let's do this. Okay.
Okay. Do you want to diffuse first or do you want to give instructions first?
I'll give instructions first.
Okay.
All right. Okay. So Emmy and I did play a little bit of this upstream so you can see a little bit of check marks and everything. We kind of skip to point two and point three because we were like, easy money.
This is easy. So let's start at 3.1. Let's not even do the other two because we beat the last one in the level of self. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. So this is five minutes, three minutes, three seconds. I'm so excited.
Oh, why is my model frozen? Oh, okay. I think my Wi-Fi is being a little shitty. So, Mubby, if the shit is wrong. Okay.
Okay. So we have, let's start with Simon Says because we did Simon Says before.
Simon Says. Yes. Okay. Got it.
Okay. Okay. Yellow blink. It's blinking yellow. One time.
We've never done Simon Says. We've never done Simon Says. No, we've never done Simon Says.
Okay. Okay. Wires. Wires. Wires.
So I have, are you there at Wires? Yes. Wires. Okay. Okay. So I have white, blue, white, and that's the only three I have. So there's three.
Okay. Cut the second wire. Boom. Noise. Okay. Simon Says.
Blinking yellow. Are you control f-ing? Yes. That's exactly what you did. Yeah, that is the smart way to do it.
One of the four colored buttons will flash using the correct table below. Press the button with the corresponding color. The original button will flash.
Okay. Sorry. I shouldn't read it. I don't get it.
So, so. Oh, fuck. I can't remember what it looks like now. Um, if it's blink, I think it's corresponded to the thing. I don't know. You can figure it out.
Okay. Well, the right button. You said it flash yellow. Yes. Yes. Well, for me, the yellow one is the right, the button on the right.
Yes. So it, oh shit. Fuck. Fuck. I'm wrong. Press the button with the corresponding color.
Yeah. So if I have yellow, then that means it's something on your side.
Green. Green. Fuck. Oh, it's a yellow and then green. Oh, no. Okay. Um, that's two strikes.
One more. Okay. Blue. Blue. Fuck. We did. Oh, I don't get it. Oh, wait. It's the serial. Oh, we were supposed to look at the serial number two.
Oh, shit. Okay. Okay. It's okay. We can retry. We can retry. That was just a practice run. We were just practicing warm up. Yeah, that was just a warm up.
Okay. Um, oh shit. I don't have Simon Says anymore. Okay. I have the button, the button. We've done that one before. It's a white button. This is whole.
Um, hold the button. Okay. Hold the button. Okay. There's a red strip.
Um, release when the countdown timer has a one in any position. Boom, baby. Okay. Okay. This is the word one. This is the one that looks like a calculator.
Remember that one? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So the word on the screen is you are spelled Y O U space A R E.
Y O U. Uh, bottom right. Bottom right. Nope. Nope. Okay. Now it is the word you are.
Remember, you have to look at step two as well.
Oh, wait, you like you and are you the letters you and are. Yes.
Okay. Um, top.
Okay.
Sure.
Okay. Okay. Now, now it's the word first.
It's the word first. And then let me know.
Oh, I think you have to ask me what like so so if it's the word first, then I have to tell you what what word it is in that eyeball location.
Okay. Okay. Okay. So what's the eyeball location? Top right. Top right is the word. Uh, so a U H H H. So now you have to go to step two.
Uh, ready? Nothing left. What? Okay. Yes. Right. No. Okay. Nice. Nice. Okay. Okay. We're getting it.
We're getting it. Now it's the word C C E E.
Um, okay. Bottom, bottom, bottom right.
Bottom right is the word nothing.
Okay. Uh, U H H H. Right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Cool. Okay. Next. Read R E A D.
Uh, middle, middle right.
Middle right is the word wait.
Uh, U H H H. No blank.
Okay. Nice. Noice. Noice. Noice. Okay. We just have one more. Fuck. I don't know what this thing's called either. It's like there's five. Fuck. Shut up snooze. Okay. Shut up. Okay. Okay.
So there's a five letters and then up arrow down arrow per letter. I think we're supposed to spell a word or something.
Five letters.
Oh, one, two, three, four, five. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I found it. Passwords. Okay. Cool. Okay. The button above and below each letter.
We're so I can do the possible only one time.
Oh, that's a lot of you, but we have 40 seconds.
Only one combination of the available letters.
Is there a word?
Uh, U G M U B is what I see right now.
Oh.
Can you press up or down and see what it says?
Yeah. Um, so, so the first column is the letters D T G Q U column.
So, so, you know how there's like four, there's five letters, right? So when I cycle through the first, oh shit, I'm dead. Okay.
Damn it.
It's okay. It's okay. We had that puzzle on the other one as well. So let's let's try to do that one first.
Then okay, I'm going to retry one more time. If you can't get this one, you want to switch perspectives? Yes. Yes.
Stupid rain downstream. I feel like we're doing 10 times worse.
It's okay. It's okay. It's the heat. It's melting your brain. Okay. Let's do passwords first. Um, so, okay. So there's five letters, right?
And the up arrows, I can cycle through each one of the letters. So the first letter in the five letter sequence has such and such letters.
Does that make sense? Okay. Do you want me to tell you what the letters are?
Or okay. So the first, the first letter in the sequence is J N D G Y T. Those are the first sequence of letters.
Okay. And then you might need a pen and paper.
I don't know. Um, so the next sequence is Y H A D J B. Okay.
And then the third sequence, because I think you're supposed to make a word out of like all of the letters.
So you're going to have to be super big brain for this. Okay. Three is J A Z F R C.
Okay. And then let me know if I'm going too fast. And then four is C K W R E I. Okay.
And then the last sequence is L E M A I O.
Okay. You're like confident.
I'm going to tell you to spell a random word and I don't think it's going to work. Can you spell the word?
Spell which? W H I C H.
You cannot spell that word, girl. You can't. You can't have the letters.
Okay. So the first, okay. Maybe the first sequence of letters will be able to help you determine which word it is.
Yeah, say it again. Say it again. I think I understand that. Say it again.
Okay. Cool. So it's J N D G Y T.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
What's the next one? What's the next one? I get it. I understand now.
Okay. Okay. D J B Y H A.
Okay. Okay. What's the next one?
Okay. J A Z F R C.
Okay. Spell three.
Three. Three. Three. Three.
Oh my God. You're so smart.
Okay. What's the next one?
Okay. Okay. Okay. Simon says. Simon says.
You got this. You got this.
I didn't understand this one either. One of the four color buttons will flash using the correct table.
We'll press the button with the corresponding color.
Okay. Which one is flashing?
Blue.
Okay. Does the zero number contain a vowel?
Uh, er, er, yes.
Okay. Um, press the red one.
Red. Oh! Oh!
Okay. Okay. Now it's blue, red. Blue, red.
Blue, red.
What do I do now?
What do I do now? Blue, red?
Okay. Blue, red.
Um, try red?
Red and then...
And then, and then what?
Red, red? No, that's wrong!
Wait, I didn't understand this one either!
So, so, so the sequence on my side is...
Well, you got the first one, so you're one step closer.
So the sequence on my side is blue, red.
Okay. Blue, red. Okay. So try...
Try red and then blue?
Red. Oh!
I accidentally hit something.
I accidentally hit green and it didn't give me a fucking thing.
Oh, shit. Okay. Hold on.
Red. Oh, it's not red anymore!
It's not red anymore!
I think, I think after we get one strike,
it might affect the side of the screen.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Green, yellow.
Okay. I have two strikes now. I have two strikes now.
Oh, red, red, green.
Red, green. Oh, pug. Okay.
Blue, red, yellow. Blue, red, yellow.
Okay. Red, green, blue.
Red, green, blue.
Oh my god.
We're figuring it out. We're figuring it out.
Blue, red, fucking yellow is the last one.
So blue, red, yellow, green? Or no?
Oh, I died.
Oh, we're so close!
Really? Are we actually close?
Because, because after Simon says it's the button
and then the button's so fucking easy.
Okay. That's okay.
Okay.
Cool. So now, everybody look at,
look at Amy's perspective.
We're gonna switch.
We're gonna switch sides.
Yes.
I got you, dog.
I got you.
I need a little smaller there.
Which one did you do?
Oh, wait.
I can only do the first bomb.
Oh, what?
Oh, fuck, because you had to redo the tutorial and everything?
Mm-hmm.
Okay, we can do this usually.
It's okay. Okay, cool.
Okey-doke.
All right. Let me go to section two, yeah.
Okay, start. This is easy. This is easy.
Okay. Sounds good. We're gonna spree-run this shit.
Let's go! Let's go!
Let's go! We're record! Let's go!
Okay.
Okay, let's go. Let's go.
Um, okay.
I have the symbols. Let's go with the symbols.
Okay, symbols, symbols, symbols. Got you.
I have an upside-down question mark.
I have a B with a T in it.
I have a smiley face sticking its tongue out.
And then I have the little monkey creature with the E at the bottom.
Oh, okay, okay. I think I know what you're talking about.
What's the upside? Okay, I think I found it.
Say it one more time. Fast.
Upside-down question mark. B with a T in it.
Smiley face sticking its tongue out.
And the little monkey with the creature, the triangle creature.
Okay. Cool, cool, cool. Okay, B with a T.
Creature, question mark, smiley face.
Okay, done, done, done, done.
Okay, next is a button. It's blue and it shows a board on it.
Oh, shit. Oh, where the fuck is that in the fucking thing?
Where the fuck is that in the- Is it at the top? Is it at the bottom?
It's a board. It's a blue. It's a blue button that says a board.
I can't find the fucking page in the manual.
Dude, can't you laugh?
Can't you laugh it?
Button, button. Oh, okay, there it is.
A blue board.
If the button is blue and it says a board, hold the button.
I refer to the- Okay, hold the button.
Wait.
The color. White. Release the button at one.
At one? Anywhere?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I have to wait, okay.
House.
It was real.
How's yours?
Okay, next is a button.
I have wires. I have wires.
Is that six? One, two, three, four.
Five, five, five, five, five.
Five, okay.
Three yellow, a-a-a, one white, and one blue.
Three yellow, one white, and one blue,
three yellow, one white, and one blue,
uh uh three yellow one white one blue three yellow one white one blue uh uh uh uh uh cut the first one here
no no okay three yellow wait what three yellow one white one blue yeah uh five wires yeah three
yellow one white one okay that's five yeah it's the last one is black there's no black otherwise
cut exactly one red wire there's no red wire there's no black wires cut the second wire oh
i'm stupid okay we did it okay we did it okay good job team yeah high five high five
that was the lowest counting on my finger i was like three yellow one white one blue how many is that
okay that's fine okay now i can do all the two the two levels okay nice skip to two point four
two point four okay start yeah okay this is so stressful
okay um okay i have the symbols symbols symbols let me know i have a star i have a a swoop
like a like a cowlick i have two k's that are back to back and i have um i'm melting three i guess
okay cool okay uh cowlick k three star okay okay next i have the maps with the with the two what the
fuck oh the maze the maze the maze yeah okay oh fuck okay uh uh where is your little dude it's
okay so um one green thing is on uh wait which side is the numbers on when we did the map the
first time oh uh let's do uh eight letters down numbers across okay one a b c okay d two is one
green circle um okay and then b five is the other green circle okay cool okay where's uh
your little dude my little thing is next to the first green circle so so uh uh for the left of it
on top of it on top of it so see you too uh okay wait wait numbers numbers up down no up no
numbers across one two three down one across one two three down one across yes yes yes sorry okay
where where's the triangle that's where the triangle is oh shit no no where's your little
red the the white thing the white thing um one two three four five six down and then um one two
three four five across okay okay um okay go go go go go go go go one go one right
okay and then one two three four up okay now one left you should be in the one of the circles
okay one up one left one down one left one down one left okay okay next I have nice
next I have the colors it flashed green uh oh Simon says Simon says yeah Simon says
uh uh god I don't want to control I've got I'm such a weakling I'm a cow okay okay uh uh uh uh
any strikes no okay uh any any vowel in the serial number oh shit where's the serial number
oh fuck where's the serial number any vowel any vowels no I don't think so no no vowels okay okay um
then then then what's the flashing green hurry up we have thirty seconds okay uh green hit green
okay okay what's next green green green green green yellow wrong oh shit it might be might be
fuck uh then it's okay one strike uh is it still flashing green green green yellow yellow
yellow yellow yellow fly I can't press green brother I didn't hear you say yellow twice
two strikes two strikes is it still green green if it's green green then blue blue I'm dead
okay oh I died I'm sorry to break it to you though we died it's okay it's okay
god my wifi is at one bar that's crazy you sound fine it's okay okay clue clue okay
should I show you one more yeah yeah okay okay and then we switch we got this we got that dog in us
even though we're both the cat girls are you are you a cat girl of course I'm a cat girl okay um I
have six now two black sorry six wires two black two whites one red and one yellow oh fuck two black
two white one red one yellow yeah yeah one red one yellow uh there's one yellow there's more than
one white two white cut the fourth wire no wait can I count wait I can't count I can't count I can't
count okay the button Simon says Simon says okay okay what's the color what is the color red
red how many uh you have one strike what's the serial number is that does it have any vowels
no no vowels okay uh one strike red flash click red okay now it's um red blue red blue click red blue
okay um red blue blue red blue blue follow it red blue blue
oh we did it we did it okay now it's just the map okay okay okay okay okay so so letters going down
numbers going across right yes oh fuck yes okay so I have so the two uh the two green circles are on um
um one a b c d one d it's nuts d five one two three d four and one two three four five six
d four and d six okay cool okay um and the triangle uh uh do you need to know where the triangle is
yes please okay I'm in the I'm in the total top left um okay and the triangle is on c three
c three c three okay okay this is easy uh two uh two right three down uh two down sorry
what we did it oh fuck you scared me I thought you died again I was like isn't it a little early
okay okay no we did it no you did it you stole from the back I feel thank you I am hey it's all
because of you hey I should have switched our little thingies what do you mean oh the little
react yeah like you're the one with the manual the reason I had it like that is because of the
the fan art that voltkin made who the the guy who made the the fan are on the twitter on twitter
oh oh right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I'll see what you did okay okay okay here I'll open the
manual now you can you can try beating that okay let's go let's go we got this if we beat
wait you just did 3.1 three oh you did two okay I did 2.4 okay you did 2.4 I will do 3.1 which
we could not be earlier let me know when you're ready I'm ready okay I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
um
oh god that's something you're gonna like
Jesus fucking Christ that's fucking Christ I might hear that shit in my night
okay uh a red abort button oh shit
um Amy you're not gonna like this we have a new one
okay so read a board button
okay um hold the button okay uh red strip
okay release on the countdown countdown timer has one in any position
oh god damn it we just missed it okay five four three two one do you want to do the one that
you haven't done before or the one that you've done before just the one that I've done before
okay uh it's the one with the letter on the screen and then there's four numbers at the bottom
oh god damn it it's the one that's like all click the button in the second position whatever
okay okay okay um so there's a three on the screen okay uh press the button in the third position
okay which is one the number one okay the number one I have now have two
okay press the button in the same position as you pressed in in stage one so third position
okay third position that was the letter two letter number okay four four first button labeled four
four okay that's in the fourth position okay two
press the button in the first position first position to this little number four I'm gonna say
letter again okay uh three in the same label in the same uh press the button with the same label
as you press in stage four four was the four yeah yeah let's go let's go okay okay the one you
have to do before is morse code morse code okay I have it open um okay
okay
dot dash dot dot dash dot dot what wait hold on let me reset hold on it's dash dot dot
dot dash dot wait when does the fucking reset okay that's resetting
dash dot dot it's just dash dot dot dash dot dot dash dot dot dot okay I think it's dash
dot dot dot and then the the m hurts I don't know if you need that or not um
dash dot dot dot
what's the word what word it's it's it's a 3.505 mh mhc are you all the wrong one
one it's morse code right morse it's a radio looking at thing multiple it's okay wait
sorry reset it there's multiple letters I thought there was just one letter so reset it oh okay
I haven't done anything okay okay oh fuck I accidentally did something I did make do oh yeah
okay I have one strike now but nothing has changed okay um actually let me double check dash dash
dot dash dot dot dot dash dot dot
dash dot dot dot um okay I don't think I have the brain power for this
okay well can you try
can you change the frequency that's what you're supposed to do right I can't yes
okay and I submit it okay try putting at 3.535 that's just a guess 3 5 3 5 nope and we have
55 seconds left okay 3 5 3 5 5 2 3 5 5 2 5 5 fuck what happened yeah I die damn it I was just
guessing I'm sorry that's my fault it's new it's a difficult actually you shouldn't tell me but
it's just like so the morse code is saying a word and you're supposed to tell me like all of the
morse code and I'm supposed to put like like each each code is for like one letter and I have to put
the letters together together to make a word and then oh shit and then when I find the word I have
to tell you which frequency to make it I think god damn that's difficult I mean that's the
point of the game right that's true okay okay let's try over to that let's let's go again okay okay
got this hopefully there's nothing scary I see wires already in the dark okay I'll find the wires
okay wires oh it's a full stack baby there's six okay what color are they
two black one white one blue two yellow
cut the last wire cut the last wire oh yeah I may have okay nice okay here now we have
that calculator thing again with the words calculator with the words oh yeah they're
what's the display what's the display t-h-e-r-e
okay um bottom right word u the letter u okay u-h-h-u-h sure next what okay got it okay
okay fuck I need to snooze this thing okay it's the word led or led led okay uh middle left
middle left is your with the apostrophe your spelt which way
oh you with the apostrophe why why are you the apostrophe re the conjunction of you are
okay um you you're you are you oh fuck ah why are you why okay well I already I already failed
there's another there's another word it's read re a d okay um middle right it blank it's the word
blank fuck hold on don't tell me yet the lights are off okay uh while the lights are off let me
tell you the next one is the one that you got the letter three from the the word three from
it's that puzzle okay okay uh now you can tell me the words the word the word is the middle right
wait right okay right okay I got that one okay and then the next one is nothing nothing's on the
screen there's nothing on the bottom left bottom left bottom left is aha spelled h u h h u h okay uh uh
uh huh okay we got it we got it um and then the last one is the passwords I don't get passwords
yeah the one that you got the word three from that you were super smart and then you got
th re okay got it got it got it got it got it okay tell me the first one okay z a h g p j
okay next one okay my f i okay next one p b c g t n okay spell after after
uh
okay there we go okay no no no I just fat figured something
let's go oh my god we did it I'm so proud of us I'm so proud of us too let's go
no I wish we could actually clap our hands together right now I know someday maybe someday
okay off collab god I'm warm right off collab dude I'm so warm I have a shirt that has a built-in
bra in it so I can't even take it off but it's a long sleeve shirt just take it off what's the
problem I don't want to have my tits hanging out you know no I don't know what you mean
free the nipple free the nipple do you want to do you want to disarm next or yeah sure yes
okay okay um do I have to do all of section two to get section three um I do not know
because it's not I don't think so it's not letting me go to section three yeah so let's
try I think I just did the first one in the fourth one and I unlocked section oh so maybe
you need two then okay yeah okay um I have symbols oh god you're starting already okay
yeah uh what are they a star a copyright symbol a little cowlick and a melting three again
that's the same shit I don't know wait wait cowlick k three star no no c copyright symbol
like oh c oh copyright symbol are oh copyright cowlick three star okay um I have a yellow button
that says hold okay okay um um yellow button this is whole yellow button this is whole yellow
button this is whole okay if the yellow button is if the button is yellow hold the button and okay
hold the button yellow yellow strip release five five any position okay
yes okay next okay okay okay letters going letters going down right yes okay okay okay
so I have a triangle at a one two three four wait tell me those circles first tell me the
circles first okay circles um a b c d e okay f um f four is one f four and then a b
wait what there's no f four one two three four wait a b c d e f a b c d e f oh that's the last one
oh I see I'm I can't count either I don't know my alphabet apparently okay nice okay okay f four is
one and then b b five yeah b five is the other one and then a triangle at um a six and then I'm
right next to the f uh four circle f four circle left or right up on the left on the left on the left
so your f three okay okay um okay go left one up one right two up one left two up one left one
up one one two three four to the right then up one and then right one let's go okay next okay cool okay
I have the the number calculator thing there's a four on the screen
where the fuck is it do you remember what that one's called oh I found it okay on the
subject of memory okay there's a four on the screen uh press the button in the fourth position
four okay um the next one is a three uh first position okay that's a three okay okay the next
one's a three again third position oh fuck okay the next one is a one
same position as the one you press in stage one so that would be the fourth position okay okay cool
that one again same label as stage one was that four yeah yeah okay cool cool
yay that was easy that was easy yeah that was pretty easy okay did you unlock stage three
let me see um let me treat yes I unlocked stage three
okay should I try let's go to two yeah go to two
three point two you mean yeah yeah three point two okay start it gives us five minutes that feels
like a long time right for real when you're fighting for your life it does seem like a long time
okay I don't see anything what what oh sorry it was upside down okay I have um one I have six wires
is that six okay if it's all of them then it's six okay I have three yellow ones uh two red ones
and one blue one um did you have any red I just said I had three red I need two red okay okay uh
cut the fourth wire okay good okay cool next I have um the color Simon says oh Simon says okay
uh bowel in serial number yes no maybe so
no no okay uh oh my god sorry my light's turned off um it's flashing red it's flashing blue
hit blue I thought the ant came back to your water bottle bro okay blue okay um now it's flashing
red green red green blue green
what the fuck what I didn't know that the freaking um the okay red green green red green green
blue green green
red green green yellow blue green green red
oh my god did we do it okay we did it okay okay noise next one I've never seen before so
there's one two three it's like a square with one two three on the left and then abc on the right
and then there's like wires oh this looks complicated okay we have three minutes there's
arrows right on top and bottom yeah there's an error on the top and then error on the bottom
okay god I can't fucking read let me let me try to fucking
okay what the fuck does that mean okay what color are the wires uh red and blue I mean
red red and black red and black brother color black okay hold on what does that mean what do you mean
oh oh it's the first wire what's the color the first wire red red red okay cut if connected to
c is connected to c it's connected to b it's connected on the left side to one and then it goes to b
and then the black wire is connected to the three and it's also connected to the b
fuck me okay um oh I get it I get it okay so so it's one b is the red right
yes yes okay what's the black one three b three b oh nice uh cut if connected to b yeah cut the
third black wire connected to b okay now okay now what's on your screen the same thing oh oh oh oh
you need a you need a press an arrow I think oh which one
upper down cut the wire to the direction I don't know click down maybe
okay okay okay okay so now I have um four five six on the left and then abc on the right
so um four is connected to four is a blue wire and it's connected to a five is a red
cut that one oh cut no what for a yeah it was a blue wire oh I think you have to start from
from one to one down okay start start from one
start from one there's no one there's no one okay then they go to the next it's the first one four
it's four five six oh fuck oh shit my nuts oh my goodness okay what's the next one okay five is a
red wire connected to a and then six is a black wire connected to c and I have 30 seconds left
red wire that's connected to c cut if connected to a or c so cut the red wire
you just made me die okay I think what the issue is I think on the first panel I had to tell you
everything I thought we just need to cut one wire but no I think we have to cut every single one
and then we can move on to the next panel I think I didn't quite get it but it's okay
press retry oh okay that's okay then do over time I hope you get this again I want to
try to decode it oh there's two sides of this oh fuck me okay okay so let's start with the wires
there's three wires two black and one blue two black one blue two black one blue two black one blue
sorry I'm scrolling two black one blue ah that's the wrong fucking thing three wires two black one
three wires two black one blue
cut the last water a white wire no oh shit if there's no red wires cut the second wire might be
okay I can't read okay okay okay it's okay um let's start with Simon says again um it's green
and we have one we have one strike vowel wait vowel oh vowel vowel um vowel vowel is a is a vowel
yes okay yes one strike vowel what color green green yellow hit yellow oh sorry blue
fuck me okay a yellow hit yellow I didn't blue it it made me explode oh shit might be
hold on one more time one more time let me redo myself you want to try one more time
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever I need myself okay okay okay I can't see anything oh what is this
okay wires again um one two three five wires two black one white one red and one blue
okay uh one red mm-hmm is there more than one yellow there's no yellow
fuck uh you have a black cut the first wire okay um okay Simon says again um okay there's no strikes
right no strikes no vowels and right now it's flashing um red blue hit blue okay um okay red red
blue blue
red red yellow blue blue red
okay
excuse me okay so now we have wires again this time they run um
vertical vertical they run vertical so there's a no it's not the same one as before
I know it's complicated wires there's a fucking bend diagram
okay hold on hell fuck I need a I might need a pull out pencil and paper for this shit
okay it's okay we still have three minutes you got this you got this okay um stop calling me I'm mine
I'm mine so there's four wires okay are there like stars at the bottom and everything and
then lights at the top there's lights at the top but there's no stars okay no stars oh hold on let me
look at the okay okay all right so all the leds are on no
there's okay you're gonna have to be so fucking specific with this shit okay I'll describe it all
is that okay yeah yeah okay let me turn my game volume down it's so loud right now Jesus Christ
shut up okay so there's a red wire okay that's the first one and then there's a space and then
there's another red wire and then there's a blue wire and then there's a white wire and then it's
blank again okay okay and then at the top okay hold on do it like this say light color and then
there's no stars at all right so just say the whether it has a light and then what color the
wire is okay red with light red with no light blue hold on go slow down slow down okay okay red with
light um okay red with light and then the next one red with no light red with no light red with no
light red with no light red with no light what the fuck red with no light okay okay blue with light
blue with light okay okay next one okay okay white with no light white with no light
okay god it's just like fucking math class all over again aren't you good at math no i hated this type
of math fucking algebra miss me with that shit okay um cut the wire if the last digit of the serial
number is even do not cut the wire okay don't cut the wire that has red and light don't cut that one
okay um the last digit of the serial number is eight okay so i think if it's red and blue but
it's not red and blue fuck oh my god there's only 45 seconds left oh fuck i'm an idiot okay okay hold
on hold on hold on hold on so so so if it's red with light uh cut the wire if the bomb has two or
more batteries it has two or more batteries yes okay cut that one the red with the red light yeah
okay okay okay okay what's the next one again red with no light red with no light is s um s s s
cut the wire if the last digit of the serial number is even so cut yes cut that one okay okay okay
cut the wire if the bomb has a parallel port what the fuck there's a parallel port
oh my god i got at the last moment oh my god it made sense in my brain at the last moment okay
so what i thought it was okay so there's like multiple venn diagrams crossing each other right
i thought it was like math where you have to like put it like factor in all of the variables
and you only look at the area that's inside of like all of the variables but variables together
but that's not how that works you only look at two variables or more okay okay okay okay okay
you want to switch yes we can switch okay do you want to do that level yes okay yes i want you to
listen i want suffering with you i know my suffering i was there the whole time i've been suffering
okay whatever you're ready i'm ready right now okay dogs let me open
i'll drink with you yeah
cheers
that's what it is in japanese okay um i see the venn diagram one let's just start with wires
it is six wires two white one yellow three yellow one blue
not in that order by the way not in that order two white three yellow there's no red okay a
cut the last wire cut the last wire pug okay uh the numbers the numbers on the screen the number on
the screen okay what's the display four um press the button in the fourth position four that's
number four okay and then four press the button in the same position as you press in stage one
so fourth earth position yeah that's number one okay three um
which stage are we in third um press the button in the third position that's the number four
then three um press the button in the same position as you press in stage two
that's the second position or the first position fuck first position fuck no okay uh
no we have to start all over again okay two it's the number two press the button in the second
position four okay second position two this is number two press the button in the same
position as you press in stage one that's second position yeah is it okay okay yes uh one press
the button the same label you pressed s is in stage two four okay that was in the second position
two press the button in the first position that's the number two
three press the button with the same label as you pressed in stage four so two two oh good
thank you remember it okay okay all right um the last one is the one with the bend diagrams
is the complex wires that you had before the one with the lights and then stuff
except this time i have all of the wires oh fuck me okay so let me read it look at each wire
there's an okay four and four use the vendor here below so whether or not to cut the wires each
wire may be striped with multiple colors okay they're not just let you know okay okay so it's just um
okay sure i think i can get it okay so do i have to find which vent diagram to use
yes so i'll read you what the uh elements of the wire is and then you find that position on the
vent diagram you correspond that letter to the little chart and then even easy lemon squeezy okay
the first one is no light red no star none of these have stars
red yes red
no light red
so because there's no other elements you would just do the one that's only red
okay um overlaps so do i tell you now whether or not to cut it
yes okay cut the wire if the last digit of the serial number is even
i heard cut the wire in my fingers slipped okay it's five it's not fucking even okay the next one
is light red light red light light uh red oh led red
30 seconds i'm shall we uh same same thing same thing so i don't touch it okay um uh no light white
i don't think that's on there there's no there's no light oh fuck uh i died there's no white wires
yeah right so i think we just have to skip that one in that case okay i'm going to retry i'm going
to press retry okay okay okay okay i think we got this i think we got this bro okay now that we
both experienced it fucking hell oh oh oh okay uh wires normal wires okay there are one two three four
five it's one yellow one black one blue two white
is the last wire black it's white
say it again sorry yeah no worries it's one yellow one black one blue two white
okay cut the first wire cut the first wire pog okay uh numbers the number on the screen
um okay what's the display three okay press the button in the third position three that's
number three okay um then we have one only press the button labeled four uh so the first position
okay number one press the button with the same label as you press in stage two brother what did i
say it was four one you didn't say anything i fuck what's it water four it was four okay pog
okay pog uh i can't see she oh it's four four four okay press the button in the same with uh in the
same position as you press in stage two um is that one oh nice okay okay three okay press the button
in the same label as you press this no no there's two now there's two on the screen two there's two
oh yeah sorry press the button with the same label as you press in stage two
is that one or four was that one or four was that one or four oh fuck was that one or four
four oh my god oh my god oh my god god bless god bless okay okay okay now i have the same that
you had earlier that was one two three abc abc do you remember the name of that like what that was
called nope okay not at all okay okay okay let me look for it i think i might have been closer to
the middle oh yep within this one yeah that should hurt my brain that should make no sense to my brain
okay so if you want to go to the next level you hit the down button if you want to go to the
previous level you hit the up button okay okay do not switch until you're sure that you have cut
all the necessary wires though okay on the current panel okay okay hi hi um wire currents are cumulative
all over panels within the module okay okay tell me um tell me what the wires look like
yeah i'll give it to you one by one it's one b red one b
so wire currents yep yep okay so don't cut it okay don't cut it the next one is two red b red two b
two yes the second wire is red and it's connected to cut it cut it cut it cut it nice okay third wire
is black connected to b cut it cut it pog okay down i'm going down okay nice nice we got a light
the next one is fifth wire is red connected to c
um don't cut it don't cut it okay next is sixth wire is black c
cut it cut it nice okay next one okay we only have 40 seconds seven black c
don't cut it don't cut it red eight c
30 seconds don't cut it don't cut it uh red nine c
don't cut it okay nice oh fuck no that was wrong what
seven black c eight red c nine red c
no don't cut any of them you said the seventh black connected to c yeah
eighth eighth red red oh i side i don't know what i did wrong what the fuck happened there
were we on the last level i think that that was second to last oh hey at least i kind of got it
yeah you live yeah i had hope for a long time there okay let's do let's do one more game and then um
we'll stop there okay doki it's sweaty okay oh shit the timer started already um
uh let's do wires first black uh blue white red god how many
one of each four sorry four so there's one of each yeah yeah yeah yeah
one of each black got the first one oh the black cool okay uh numbers
okay i'm ready one um second position fuck i can't see that's three okay
okay uh three first position first position does the number two okay one three one two okay two
uh same label as you pressed in stage one uh uh fuck i just said it to myself i think it's three
okay that's second position um four um same position as you pressed in stage two
same position same position say two does first position okay that's three uh four four
same label as you pressed in stage three three uh it's that two or one was that two or one same
label two or one i'm gonna say it's one
fuck that was wrong okay my b okay three three we're starting over it's three oh
sure we're starting over okay um yeah we're starting over uh third position third position is the number one
okay three label three first position first position this number one okay it's one one so far
third position first position two same label as stage one one that's in the fourth position god
damn okay um three uh same position as stage two i think it's the third position no it was the
first position oh damn it did we have to start over again hold on hold on let me let me let me
fuck let me just kill myself real quick let me kill myself bro i can't
well i accidentally solved um the complex wires so uh we can just keep doing
i accidentally solved it because i just spam clicked every single one because i don't have any i
can't die anymore for what a reason that or i accidentally just clicked every single one
that was correct anyways um so back to numbers uh two is displayed oh fuck second position
but it's the second but it's the second stage it's second stage oh um same position as you
pressed in stage one brother i can't remember that brother you gotta remember it fuck stage one
has the first but nope so i really did just accidentally cut every single one of the complex
wires that's so fucking funny okay hold on you want to get one dub before we end let's get one
dub before we end okay did you want to defuse or do you want me to defuse i'll try defusing okay
sounds good let me end those games then because i accidentally hit retry return to office okay
okay i'll do something easy i'll do a hidden message does that work okay i don't know why
they're titled this way but okay ready let it all i i all right i'm locked in are you ready kids
i i captain i can't simon says first okay i can't hear you okay vowel yes no
oh no no uh uh uh what color red red blue hit blue
now you got a bunch of us stuck in my head red blue red blue blue red
no not blue red red blue now we have one strike though yellow green
no oh fuck did you say it doesn't contain it about i'm a dumb ass holy shit
it didn't contain a vowel oh god damn i'm not locked in okay red blue two strikes red blue okay
yellow green yes yes i'm a hundred percent certain okay okay red blue green red blue green
yellow green blue okay red blue green yellow okay perfect uh yellow green blue red
okay red blue green yellow yellow oh there's more red blue green yellow yellow yellow green blue red
red okay done okay now i have six wires okay uh three three four blue and two yellow four blue
two yellow oh god if there's no yellow wires nope if there's no two yellow two yellow yeah
oh god i gotta lock in and read this shit if there's no red wires no red right no cut the last one
got it okay okay so now the last one is it's it's the the words i think um where remember you
there's like oh the passwords yeah yeah okay okay where is it okay i see oh my god
so okay the first one is w ready mm-hmm okay w f e q v x and that's it so you have to find one
of the words on like in the first column that starts with you know one of those letters
okay did you find it mm-hmm okay so the next one is the next position is t q d i e j and yeah
one more time t q d i e j what the fuck
do none of the none of the words in the second column have
wait i don't get it wait so is it not like you you find a word that has all all of the combinations
no so the first letter in the first position is going to be the first letter in the word
okay right yeah okay so you find one of the letters in that first column
fuck i can't even hear myself speak you find one of the letters in that first column
that corresponds to any of the letters that i say and then you have to continue on horizontally
until until the until like you can understand um so can you can you say the first column
i just exploded oh because i find i found w and then i was like but for like the next letter it
doesn't it doesn't fit well like in that whole column all of the words should start with no
i'm not calm row in the whole row all the words should start with w then right right yeah but like
the second letter it doesn't fit i can well it only fits in one of them in the row right right
but but none of them have the second letter oh none of them had the second letter yeah wait hold on
overtime we have to get a dub okay we'll get a double we'll get a dub
um okay wires six wires three blue one white one black
three blue one white one black three blue one six wires yes three blue one white one black
three blue one white one black there are no yellow wires what's the last digit of the zero number
is it odd yes okay cut the third wire okay okay um let's do the the the
calculator with the words so okay cool it says lead le ad le ad what's the
bottom right word sure so how do you spell that s you are e s you are e okay
cause it's not a good time to burp okay you are spelled why oh you are e okay
um they are so t h e y a re okay what's the middle left why oh you why oh you
why are you sure s you are e you are you are e okay um and oh and oh bottom
right sorry bottom right press press right middle yes wait wait wait wait wait
wait the lights are off okay okay okay okay okay ready okay good good
we're done we're done okay okay okay last one is the letters again with the
up and down letter oh the password the password yeah fuck okay this truly a
redemption of a lifetime okay let's go okay let's go okay first position first
letter is s v m i b x yeah okay first second one is m e x v n h okay okay
third one is a w okay sorry keep going yeah continue the sequence a w k y h q yeah okay I think you
have to smell the words small okay
we did it we went to schmorty pans we are what are we even doing as streamers we
should be at the FBI diffusing bombs good job team good job high five high
five next time there's a tarot attack they should have called upon the help of
an immediate kai foo oh my god okay
do you have any last words kai foo before we end go check out kai foo's channel she
puts she posts ASMR too and we're gonna do a collab together we're gonna oh my god yeah we're both
realize you're gonna spoil that sorry yeah we're gonna be doing um an ASMR collab we're gonna be
doing two ASMR collabs together yeah one on my channel one on her channel and it's gonna be um
definitely okay no no you need to tell it like it is it's gonna be cringe but it's like cringe in
like a good way okay it is cringe but in a good way we embrace the cringe to the highest degree
we're cooking we're high-key cooking for a week we cooked so hard it got burnt
okay i'm gonna raid she be after this
unless you wanted to keep streaming kai foo or are you gonna end too okay okay okay okay yeah
i just wanted to collab with you today because i've always wanted to
yeah ever since your debut i knew i knew i wanted to collab with me
oh she's muted my bad
um hold on will it be an off collab no
if only i wish maybe one day there you go anyways oh so what emi said is we're gonna
have a collab my stream it will be an ASMR collab a video yes two videos one on each channel
you should watch both of them because they're funny they are one will make you cream the other
will make you scream baby the other will make you cry it will make you relive old trauma
at least the plot twist is good okay oh yes okay i'm gonna go to my ending screen um okay yeah
see you tomorrow for my viewers go watch emi stream tomorrow go watch my stream tomorrow
mm